john fetterman for example has called  for the mass release  of convicts who are serving life  sentences in prison and by the way uh  life sentence in prison this is not one  of those we always hear about the  mythological people that are  in prison because they you know had a  little bit of weed or something and they  were next to you know they get they get  10 years in prison supposedly you get a  life sentence uh it's not for weed we  could tell you that but he wants to  release a lot of them let's listen to  that  we have a catastrophic bottleneck in our  prisons of over 5 000 men and women  condemned to die in prison  and many of them i believe personally  are deserving of a second chance  catastrophic bottleneck he says in fact  john fetterman has been more specific  talking about this and has said that he  wants to release up to one-third of the  prisoners who are serving life sentences  because of the um bottleneck